يسعدنا ان يكون معنا في الاستوديو التغطيه
هنا في اروقه المؤتمر وزير الخارجيه
الفنلندي بك هافيستو مع الوزير مرحبا بك
عرضتم تزويد اوكرانيا بدبابات متطوره من
طراز ليوبارد الالمانيه
ولكن قلت من هذا الامر لا يتم الا بعد
الحصول على تصريح من المانيا الى اين وصل
هذا العرض
طبعا
قدمت احد عشر حسنا من المساعدات العسكريه
لوكرانيا طبعا الان نحن بصدد همم ارسال
حزمه جديده 55 مليار عفوا همم
تحتاج الى دبابات وهناك مساورات جاريه مع
المانيا نحن قلنا ان لدينا في مخزوناتنا
دبابات اثنين وطبعا المانيا و بولندا
ستقدم اعداد اكبر لكن هذا من خلال خدمه
هذه وصيانتي والتدريب على الدبابات
هل لديكم اي اجابه محدده بخصوص مساله
موافقه المانيا من عدمها قلت ان هناك
اجتماع للوزراء الدفاع التحالف الغربي في
رمشتاين في المانيا الجمعه المقبل بعد
يومين من الان هل حصلتم على اي تعهدات من
المانيا بالموافقه كماهيا مع الموقف
الغربي برمته
في المانيا
ووزيره الدفاع الجديد سوف يستلم مهام
منصبه وهذا الامر سيحتاج بعض الوقت لاتخاذ
لقرار وحسب فهمي القرار النهائي لم يتخذ
بعض في المانيا لكن طبعا لان الدبابات
اثنان مصنوعه في المانيا واي دبابات ترسل
الى اوكرانيا تحتاج الى موافقه الصانع
الاصليه
هذا يعني هل يمكن ان نصرف هذا بانه تلكؤ
من المانيا ان الموقف الغربي غير موحد
بخصوص مساله تزويد اوكرانيا
بالاسلحه المتطوره هل يعذب ذلك من
الاتهامات الروسيه بان اوكرانيا تقود حربا
بالوكاله نيابه عن الحلفاء الغربيين
برمتهم
الاتحاد الاوروبي
فخور لان الاتحاد الاوروبي تستجاب منذ
البدايه ضد الهجوم الروسيه على اوكرانيا
وايضا من خلال تقديم
المساعدات العسكريه والدعم العسكري
لاوكرانيا بالطبع وحده اوروبي حتى الان تم
المحافظاتها المحافظه عليها دعما لاكرانيا
لكن كثير من هذه الامور لها طبيعه ماديه
وايضا لها علاقه باليات القرار الوطني لكل
دوله
يعني هذا الامر مثير للغايه يعني دعني
اذكرك بان رئيسه حكومتكم سنه مارين قالت
الشهر الماضي ان اوروبا ليست قويه بالقدر
الكافي لمواجهه موسكو حاليا وان اوروبا
ستكون في مازق شديد همم ان لم تلتزم
الولايات المتحده بتعهداتها الدفاعيه عن
اوروبا اليس من الحكمه مراجعه الموقف
الاوروبي من حرب لا تستطيعون الفوز بها
بدون حليف يجلس امنا على بعد الاف الاميال
من اوروبا يفصله عنكم محيط ضخم
اعتقد ان عندما ننظر الى الامور من السياق
حنفي الناتو نحن تقدمنا بطلب الانضمام الى
حرف النايته
والتحالف الدفاعي بين اوروبا
والولايات المتحده عبر الاطلنطي جزء لا
يتجزا من الحاجات الدفاعيه اللي اوروبا
والولايات المتحده معنا في هذا الموقف لكن
في نفس الوقت مهم لا اوروبا ان تعزز
قدراتها الدفاعيه الذاتيه مررنا بفتره من
السلام طويله لم نمر بايه حروب والان
البلدان الاوروبيه بدات تراجع انفاقاتها
الدفاعيه وبعض البلدان زادت في ذلك
بالنسبه الانفاق العسكري بسبب التغيرات
شمال الاطلسيه لما وصلت الامور مع تركيا
بعد مذكره التفاهم الثلاثيه التي وقعتموها
مع السويد وتركيا وانقره بخصوص هذا الصدد
كانت لدى تركيا نطالب محددها لوفيت بهذه
المطالب
[موسيقى]
فنلندا
نحن هناك 28 بلدي
وهنغاريا ما تزال ولم توفقاري ليست لديها
شروط معينه لكن في تركيا لدينا التفاهم
الذي تم فيه مديريه في الصف الماضي اعتقد
اننا همم نفذنا ما علينا في ما يتعلق بهم
مكافحه الارهاب
حزب العمال القردستاني لكن على مستوى
اللقاءات بين على مستوى الوزارات كانت
لقاءات ممتازه الان نحن ننتظر القرارات
السياسه نعلم ان في تركيا انتخابات قادمه
وزير الخارج الان
بحث التعاون العسكري التركي الامريكي وهو
ايضا قد يكون جزءا من الحل في قضيتنا ايضا